but an nhp trooper also just pulled over  so that only adds to the slowing  as the flashing lights maybe get a  little bit of a distraction you got the  looky-loos over there  uh here we are over on the right-hand  shoulder there's the nhp trooper and  there is traffic crawling along  now normally they put something up on  the overhead size there and then they  just did that  uh live on television how about that so  that lane is closed that's the right  lane in the right shoulder that are  closed the rest of the freeway is moving  through there but you're going to lose  a couple of minutes of travel time until  they get that cleared out